Hi, I'm Gabrielle and
I'm going to be your instructor for
this short course on Swift Syntax.
Swift is already having a huge
impact on iOS development.
It's fast, concise, easy to read, and
comes with tools like playgrounds that
make it easier than ever
to visualize your code.
A welcoming language for beginner and
intermediate programmers,
Swift makes the road to building your
own iOS apps considerably less steep.
Fantastic resources for
learning Swift are easy to find.
Not least among them is Apple's guide,
The Swift Programming Language
which we hope you'll come
to rely on as a reference.
This course hopes to offer something
that is less common among other Swift
resources, practice.
Throughout the course, we'll be
working through examples together, and
each lesson will end with a set
of exercises to get you more
comfortable with Swift's idiosyncrasies.
We'll start out with some basics
of types and operators and
practice manipulating strings and
declaring variables and constants.
Then we'll move on to what is
arguably Swifts most unique and
confounding feature.
Optional types.
We'll talk about collections and
control flow,
including lots of practice
with switch statements.
Functions and classes.
Enumerations and structs.
Which are considerably more powerful
in Swift than in other languages.
Protocols.
And will wrap things up by
exploring closure expressions.
Which can be tricky at first, but
wonderfully convenient once
you get the hang of them.
This course is designed for
programmers who have some prior
object oriented experience.
For students who,
through work with other languages
are already familiar with most of
the concepts I've just listed.
So let's get started with Swift types.